In this lesson, we're going to take a look at HLODs and how they work with your levels
of detail.
So, let's get started.
So, HLODs, you may ask, what exactly are they?
Well, they're a hierarchical level of detail.
It's a way to combine pre-existing SeticMesh actors into a single HLOD proxy mesh and
material with at-list textures.
So, using HLOD may lead to increased performances as they reduce draw calls down to one call
per proxy mesh, which is pretty convenient.
When generating HLOD proxy meshes, there are several parameters you can adjust which help
define how static mesh actors are grouped together as clusters that will ultimately
be built into proxy meshes.
Now, you don't have to use this tool, but it is available.
It's a little bit more on the old-school side, and you may find that Nenite fits the
bill just fine.
But to be able to create it, you do want to start out by going into your proxy meshes.
You can find them under your world settings.
So these proxy meshes are created from clusters of static meshes, like we mentioned.
Each cluster is going to be one draw call.
That's the benefit you get from this.
Clusters can't be merged into bigger clusters at a greater distance.
So use them for wide shots or open worlds.
No, HLOD layers can now be used to house Geo also with World Partition.
So you can use them with World Partition also.
But I want to put a note here for World Partition.
If you decide to use it with your team, keep in mind there are still some things evolving
with it, such as linking your World Partition updates with Perforce.
There can be some workarounds that you may have to tackle in that.
And we're not going to cover that here, but I want you to be aware of it.
So creating it, we're going to go to our world settings and load Hiercal LOD setup.
We're going to generate a single cluster if needed.
And this can be set to HLOD in the HLOD Outletter also, which we'll take a look at in just a
bit.
So let's hop into Unreal and take a quick look too.
From there, you want to open your Hiercal LOD Outletter and select the HLOD setup asset.
And that can be default.
So you don't necessarily have to do any heavy lifting on this particular case.
We did have an older version if you were used to it, where HLOD would list a lot more options
than it does now.
It's been pared down quite a bit.
But you want to generate your clusters.
And when you generate your clusters, you're going to be able to get the items that you
need.
Now if the actor's changing anyway, it's going to prompt you.
It'll tell you, hey, man, you need to generate those proxy meshes again.
Because that's kind of important.
Things have changed to update the HLOD cluster.
Only use build all if you have to.
As it can dirty your scene, and Unreal will let you know.
I'll say, hey, buddy, are you sure about this?
This may not be the right choice for you.
We're going to actually look at an HLOD volume also in place with an HLOD in my scene that
I've given to you.
Let's go ahead and jump into Unreal and look at the setup I have, as well as look at the
HLOD Outliner breakdown that shows some of the things that have been generated and some
overall sweeping control that you've gotten in your scene.
In Unreal, I'm going to go to my beach HLOD sample.
Let's go and click on that.
I'm going to say, don't save what we were doing.
Get that to come up.
We'll see it generate, get in there.
Now, let's go and take a look at things overall.
Let's open up our HLOD Outliner.
Let me pull it over.
You see that I have generated some HLOD objects in here.
We have a LOD actor here that has all the parts for that particular probe.
We have another one in here.
Unreal's clustering these, so let me know what has become an HLOD object.
Anytime you don't want these in here, you can delete that cluster.
You're like, hey, I don't really need this one.
This one's fine.
Nanite's handling it just fine.
I can go ahead and delete that.
You can also, as we go and open these up, look at these on an individual level.
You'll see there's advanced settings here, and it just shows you the transform options.
It isn't as robust as it used to be, or we used to have a bit more, or you have a little
bit more material control and a few other things.
Those don't quite pop up like they used to.
Things have been pretty pared down here.
You'll notice at the bottom here, we have a yellow message here.
These actors represented in the HLOD have changed, generate proxy meshes to update.
Since I've tweaked with this file a bit, I would have to just generate another proxy
meshes here for any updates or changes that I've made.
Keep that in mind.
Again, build all.
You kind of want to avoid if you don't really have to do it.
There's also regenerates your clusters, but no proxy meshes for meshes in the level.
This is your initial button that you would click, and then from there, any changes you
can do for your generated proxy meshes are found here.
Now, another thing I want to point out, there's a thing called an HLOD volume.
Type in volume here.
There's a lot here.
You'll see that I've drug in an HLOD proxy volume.
This actually acts as a container to hold a cluster of HLODs that we have built in.
I can actually use this as a priority area until Unreal to read a group of pieces of
geometry as one draw call.
You'll see this HLOD volume here.
This actually works pretty well.
This HLOD volume, you'll see, also has a few more options.
It tells you to include overlapping actors.
I can definitely tick that box on.
There are a few that are overlapping a bit in my scene.
We have a few generic brush settings in here, but we also have include actor in HLOD.
It's going to, you want to make sure that's turned on.
There's some advance with the brush settings, but it's nothing to write home about.
But overall, you can see how things work.
Now, down below, you will see a level instancing.
We're not doing that in this particular case.
Level instancing allows you to grab maybe a group of rocks, these particular ones.
If I wanted to, I can turn them into a level instance actor.
In this case, we're not covering that in this particular class.
It's a little bit more building of your game world.
From here, we're mainly going to be focusing on our HLODs.
I just wanted to point that out if you're wondering what that does.
This basically allows you to have instanced pieces of large.
You have a huge open world area and there's some rock formations and large landscapes and
just things that you've kind of mushed together.
And you have all these pieces of geometry to manage them.
You can actually create a level instance to make things a little bit lighter and unreal
will instance those pieces of geometry as an instance part of your level and make things,
it makes things a little bit more organized and categorized and reading the geometry smoother
so that your big world that you've created doesn't become too much of a bog in your scene.
So here, again, we have an HLOD volume and again, it is calculating everything in my scene the way that I want.
And if we did a comparable like we just talked about, I could grab this pieces of geometry here,
right click and you'll see level and I can create an instance level if I wanted to.
And in there, I can have living an HLOD if I wanted.
And then it would simply be able to be loaded in here.
Now there's a difference when you're working with those.
We're working in our levels here.
If I was working in a world partition, I would not be working in levels.
So there's a give and take situation there.
And we do have a class talking about that in which one of my colleagues really breaks
that down a bit easier for you.
But I just wanted to explain if there's any confusion about how that system works.
So to break it down even further, they are used by the hierarchical level of detail HLOD system
to group actors into a single HLOD cluster.
So again, like I said before, it puts them in a cluster.
When generating clusters, the Unreal Engine will override its normal generation process
in difference to manually placed volume.
So basically going to look at them as a priority area, like I mentioned before.
That's it with this lesson.
Here's a few links here that allow you to dive in a bit deeper on these topics.
In the next section, we're going to take a look at texture and material optimization.